congressional democrats say they want to
restart failed
talks to restore a 600 a week federal
unemployment benefit
for millions of americans over the
weekend after congress failed to act
president trump
issued a series of executive actions
from his new jersey golf club however
experts say those relief efforts stand
on shaky
legal ground ben tracy is at the white
house for us so ben
is the president's plan actually going
to help anyone
yeah that's the big question this
morning you know what the president is
trying to do here is simply bypass
congress which means all of this could
end up in the courts
delaying any actual aid also a lot of
what he's proposed
is costly and complicated you can't beat
the deal we made we've gotten much of
what we
wanted they didn't get what they wanted
but there wasn't actually a deal
president trump gave up on negotiations
with democrats
and is now taking unilateral actions
presidents executive orders
described in one word could be paltry in
three words
unworkable weak and far too narrow
democrats and even some republicans are
accusing the president of making
promises
he constitutionally can't keep
republican senator ben
sasse calls the president's executive
actions unconstitutional slop
it was time to act a lot of the claims
president trump made at his new jersey
golf club this weekend
simply don't add up he says he's
preventing evictions
but in reality his order directs federal
agencies to consider
whether halting evictions is necessary
the president says he's creating a new
400
weekly federal unemployment benefit but
that's far
less than the 600 benefit democrats want
to extend
and 25 percent of it would have to be
funded by states
which is unlikely given many are facing
severe budget cuts
look that would cost us about 500
million dollars
between now and the end of the year i
could take that money from testing i
don't think that's a great idea
president trump is already backtracking
saying the federal government may now
fund the full cost for some states
he is also attempting to suspend the
federal payroll tax
until the end of the year for americans
making less than one hundred thousand
dollars
but the taxes are only deferred and
would eventually have to be paid back
unless according to the president he's
reelected
if i'm victorious on november third i
plan to forgive
these taxes and make permanent cuts to
the payroll tax
now president trump doesn't actually
have the power to eliminate the payroll
tax only congress can do that and keep
in mind that the payroll tax actually
funds
social security this weekend house
speaker nancy pelosi and minority leader
schumer
said that the president's plan endangers
that program
that seniors rely on anthony ben thank
you